Super Bowl is this Sunday Super Bowl
Sunday time does it start the game
itself black I started about 6:18 I
think is when they kick off but the
pregame starts at like 11:00 in the
morning it's ridiculous right there's
just countless a lot of talk are you
gonna room for the Chiefs uh I think I
might root for Kansas cuz a mom one in
fifty fifty years but then nothing would
please me more to watch you [ __ ] weep
no matter what crime or if they win yeah
I think I want Kansas actually I don't
know why I'm weird with you with me
promise me a shower if you if I can win
of course yeah maybe that if they win
you shower every day okay that's a deal
you like rooting against the Chiefs
right Robin yeah because I want to see
Richard devastate can I just say go tell
the Chiefs fans what you want to say
will be quiet this has never happened in
my [ __ ] lifetime and I've been a
lifelong Chiefs fan man we're doing this
Kansas City thank you Bob stay to be
read thank you [ __ ] Travis Kelce
thank you honey badger thank you Frank
Clark you guys are the [ __ ] best you
made me so happy this year this is gonna
[ __ ] rule if you win I'm gonna be so
[ __ ] happy so thank you Chiefs you
[ __ ] rule let's hear Kansas said hey
why is just so important you in other
words is it because Kansas City is
really not caught up it's not a big this
is your chance to map and you know
everybody's like Oh Richard you wrote
for the Eagles - I wrote for the Eagles
because of my wife my wife grew up an
Eagles fan right so I'll root for the
Eagles for my wife but I grew up a
Chiefs fan Chiefs Royals k UJ ox oh you
wanna know I'll get you crying your dad
oh my gosh yeah I'll talk about what the
Chiefs mean to your dad always lived on
his whole life on a farm what my dad and
I grew up watching the Chiefs together
every Sunday we bought it over Jeeves
the [ __ ] Royals my dad took me to so
many Royals games we could never afford
to go to the Chiefs games but we watched
together at home and and your dad is
getting older you're getting older and
who knows how many more Chiefs games
there are exactly and I told Patrick
mahomes when I talked to him last year I
said I just I would love for my dad and
I just see achieve Super Bowl together
wow what an emotion that just came out
of you yeah
[Music]
this is I can't even describe the
emotions of going to you who do you who
you call first your father if they my
dad yeah and I thought I'll be crying my
eyes out let's take you dad
no let's hear the conversation the
Chiefs have just won the Super Bowl and
I go hello dad hi Richard how about them
trade how about this when it happened
can you believe it you remember when we
first started one and let hey we used to
cheer for Cristiano koieie the Nigerian
nightmare my dad and I got to meet him
together last night when we met then man
Cristiano Koya
oh my god and now here's now it happened
now it once we did and we're gonna keep
winning it doesn't in here I'll be
talking to you later bub okay I love you
so much dad go chiefs how about them
chief how bout them change Richard and I
hope you remembered not to shower I
don't care what that filthy Howard Stern
I'm never gonna wash away these tears
there yes all right
listen that's emotional and you're real
men because you can show your emotion
thank you I've cried over a lot of stuff
what will he be if they lose
oh my you know what I'm gonna be like
I'm gonna be bummed but I know as long
as my homes is coming back we're gonna
get there eventually but I think this is
a year this is it this is it for all
Chiefs fans